Anthony Pro was one of the many cities
across Ukraine which was hit we've
traveled from slovians that was also hit
overnight there's a massive crater here
let me take you a bit closer so that you
can see the size of it and this is right
in the middle of a residential area
behind in the background of the crater
there's a half-built res the residential
flats and what appears to be possibly a
shopping area of course they wouldn't
have known when that was hit how that it
was unoccupied at the time there were
also there's a a shot coming in to try
and do clear up some of the Met here
there was also a bus here that was just
passing by because the time of day was
right in the middle of the rush hour and
uh luckily miraculously no one was hurt
in the bus we understand that although
there were three hits in denipro
again miraculously only three people
were actually killed this seems to be a
trademark of all the attacks today is
that
um they were hitting where there were
multiple civilians in the area this is
the the um block of several blocks of of
residential Flats many of them we've
been watching them clearing out their
broken windows and and they've been
affected by just the impact of of that
big crater but a lot of the people we've
been talking to not just angry not just
saddened by this but also their resolve
about the whole purpose of of Defending
themselves against
um Putin's War has almost been
strengthened by these moles of attacks a
lot of them talking about how
um they want the rest of the world to to
stop making excuses for Vladimir Putin
and to
um declare
Russia a terrorist State and a lot of
people sort of almost reeling from this
volley and barrage of attacks across a
number of different cities clearly the
first time in the capital Kiev that for
many months that they've had the heart
of the war brought right to their
doorstep and a very again very markedly
on the donbass battlefield from where
we've just come the Russians and the
Russian troops are retreating at such a
fast pace and many many villages and
communities and towns are being
liberated on a daily basis there's a lot
of feeling there that's very markedly
there hasn't been big attacks in that
area because they're very much on the
Run backwards and
um and the ukrainians are on the march
in that area and possibly because of all
these probably because of all these
Battlefield successes on behalf of the
ukrainians plus the attack on the bridge
in Crimea uh the the Russians and
particularly Vladimir Putin is feeling
so threatened so uh embarrassed by all
the Ukrainian Battlefield successors
that he's hitting out in any way he can
by
showing to his domestic audience that
he's not going to be cowed by all these
failures on the battlefield